now John de Graaff author and producer
of the book and PBS documentary
affluenza on how America consumes this
hour-long discussion is hosted by the
close up foundation hello and welcome to
the Newseum in Arlington Virginia for
this week's edition of close up at the
Newseum hi I'm John molesky of the close
up foundation today we're going to be
talking about economic growth driven by
consumption and a documentary and book
about that called affluenza I'll
introduce you to our guests in just a
moment first I want to let you know that
we're joined today by students from
Langley High School in McLean Virginia
graduating seniors for the most part
they'll be asking questions and making
comments as we proceed in our discussion
now let me introduce you to our guest
joining us is John de Graaff John is a
veteran producer of public television
documentaries whose primetime PBS
programs include four for Earth's sake
running out of time and the one we're
talking about today affluenza he's a
visiting scholar at Evergreen State
College and a lecturer on documentary
production at the University of
Washington
additionally he's one of the authors of
the book based on the PBS program here
it is the title affluenza and we have a
doctor in the house so doctor what does
affluenza and how do you how do you get
it
well briefly it's it's it's obviously a
play on words of affluence and influenza
but it's a it's a it's a virus that's
spreading I think across the United
States of over-consuming and it has many
symptoms including things like shopping
fever and swollen expectations and
chronic congestion and so forth but we
we in the book picture over-consuming
and the the constant demand and desire
for more and more material things as a
virus what now the documentary aired a
couple years ago and what was the
motivation for the product the project
how did you come across this idea the
original motivation for the documentary
yes I was actually approached I had done
a documentary called running out of time
it ran on PBS with the same host Scott
Simon and when that premiered actually
we did a screening at the University of
Washington before it was on the air and
that woman named Vicki Robin was in the
audience she's the author of a popular
book called your money or your life
million-selling book actually and she
came down after this
actually literally grabbed me by the
shoulders and said John you need to do a
film about overconsumption and I can
help you find the money and I said oh
you just said the magic words why don't
you come down to the public station
because in public TV that's always the
problem is finding the money so indeed
she pointed me in the right direction to
the Pew Charitable Trusts and the
program emerged and we didn't have a
title for it for some time until I was
actually well into the shooting process
and was driving flying across to these
coasts to do the final final stage of
videotaping and I was reading a magazine
article that had this one throwaway word
effluence and a line it was like the the
cartoons where the light bulb goes on in
your head method affluenza this is it
this describes what we're trying to get
at and that allowed us then to make the
film that treated this subject of
over-consuming as a disease with various
symptoms various treatments and a kind
of a history in epidemiology if you will
now the normal formula is book first
film second you did it in Reverse
was there a response that led you to
write the book why did the book come up
exactly the film was Andy Warhol says
everybody gets their 15 minutes and this
was kind of my mini hit on PBS much more
popular than anything else I'd I'd ever
done and so there was a buzz about it
and in New York agent called me and said
geez a lot of people are talking about
your film I think I can can sell a book
I'd really think it should be turned
into a book and we had a lot more
material anybody who's produced public
television knows that you you've got
about 60 you know hours worth of
research and interviews and stuff for
every hour that goes on the air so
there's a lot of extra stuff and the
book gave the opportunity to go deeper
into the subject now if you just look at
this on the surface and you think of it
in political terms this would seem like
a potential liberal rant against
conservative economic policies but you
claimed in the book that the response
came from people who see themselves as
conservative and liberal who were this
touched accord yeah I think the response
was positive across the political
spectrum and in fact
the film which is is now shown in about
700 colleges around the u.s. actually
used the film it's probably show more
often in what you might consider
conservative universities like Brigham
Young and places like that then actually
in the in the Berkeley's why do you
think that is well I think the whole
issue of debt and over-consuming and and
the things involved in that strike a
chord with with conservative folks who
think you know we've got a about part of
being conservative is is being careful
about spending about these kind of
things and also we look at really the
impacts of this on things like family
and children and communities part of the
film like it's just about the targeting
of kids love you by marketers to try to
get you to spend and spend and the
pressure on your parents in order to
respond to that and I think many
conservatives certainly responded to
that they were really appalled by what
they saw marketers doing my read of both
the book and the documentary is that you
purposefully attempted to not position
this as political in one way or the
other that you tried to report it
factually and let people make their call
and sprinkled in views from liberals and
conservatives is that an accurate read
well from my perspective it is of course
the book has still been then criticized
as being too liberal in in a sense by by
some people certainly most of the anti
reviews and things of the book have come
from the right side of the political
spectrum I think because the criticism I
think because we have a larger criticism
of the whole emphasis on economic growth
and on letting the market do whatever
the market wants to do and and
constantly being obsessed with having a
higher and higher standard of living I
think that there are some conservatives
who respond well to that probably more
the social conservatives I don't think
libertarians respond well to it at all
so so it's more of a Family Values type
of reaction yes there's negative impact
on a family if you got to work too many
hours to work too many hours
if your kids are constantly at you to
buy them things that you know young kids
and nag at you and you don't know what
to do you're quite a man am I gonna feel
guilty especially if you're working too
many hours as a parent you know and I
can never see my kids but at least I can
buy them something doctor what's that
about documentary as a format a way of
getting messages out or making a
statement we look at media all the time
primarily news media but we don't focus
that much on documentary as a form well
I think most of us see our content in
drama and I think that's great and I
just don't know how to do it so I do
documentary I've been doing this for
about 25 years and I I think it allows
you often we get news in these 1 and a
half minute or 1 minute things with 8
second sound bites and all that sort of
things it's very difficult to give it
context and treat any kind of complex
subject the way it ought to be treated
so that people can understand it in
these very very short in news clips so
what documentary does is it allows you
to take a half an hour or an hour two
hours maybe to explore a subject really
in-depth and and that's what excites me
about and what I like to do what's the
level of documentary activity out there
I mean it's something like Fahrenheit
9/11 or supersized may becomes a
mainstream distributed type of product
that everybody's aware of but there's a
lot of documentary work that goes on
scenic well absolutely and and I just
thought supersize me which is a very
very funny and interesting film I
haven't seen Fahrenheit 9/11 yet but
Michael Moore has certainly helped put
documentary on the map with things like
Bowling for Columbine and Roger and me
and of course Ken Burns has done it in a
different genre with his civil war
series much straighter kind of
traditional style but still very very
popular you do have these wonderful
series on things like PBS like the
frontline series which explores the
major I think issues of our day with
in-depth complexity and and I think
balance as well what did you think it
supersize me front of you very funny
still eating at McDonald's anyway I
don't say that I've
never go there have never been there but
I think it and I don't think supersize
me leads you with necessarily lead you
to never go there
but I think it does show you the
consequences of our fast food culture
and really there's another documentary
coming out later in the summer done by a
woman who's a challenge to Spurlock and
also ate at McDonald's for every meal
and lost weight lost 2530 pounds
something like that it's probably
possible I mean if you eat only the
salads and you don't use the salad
dressing and things like that I think
you can probably lose weight eating
anywhere but that's not what most people
are doing I would tend to think that
verlox documentary wall exaggerated
without question is probably closer to
the it's not a health center yeah it's
not a health well well let's let's delve
into a little bit of the affluenza
documentary of one of the clips the
shopping mall has become an iconic place
in America you have a segment in here
about one not far down the road from
here Potomac very close visit there
back at the time when we were shooting
the program and we actually got
interested in in Potomac Mills Mall
because of a series of ads that we saw
which was very cleverly done I mean just
brilliantly produced ads with an actress
being both sort of zany and smart and
kind of telling you things like shopping
his therapy you know shop shop shop and
things and why she goes to Potomac very
funny stuff in it how many of you have
ever been to Potomac Mills raise your
hand if you've made the the sojourn okay
how many been there in the last hour now
okay well let's take a look at what a
neighborhoods let's take a look at the
clip and then we'll come back and talk a
little more about it
well those be stores really not
Tomek males attracts more visitors than
any other site in Virginia this shopping
mall is such a popular tourist
destination airlines offer excursion
flights here from distant cities and
where are you from Dallas Dallas area
Potomac Mills is a discount
super model divided into what are you
familiar all neighborhoods shopping
malls have really become the centres of
many communities children as well as
adults see a shopping center as just the
natural destination to fill a bored life
70% of us was at malls each week more
than attend churches or synagogues on
average we shop six hours a week and
spend only 40 minutes playing with our
children shop money what else matters
it's a happy go spending world reflected
in the windows of the suburban shopping
centers where they go to buy by 1987
America had more shopping malls than
high schools there's a that's we ended
that purposefully on a fairly dramatic
statement more shopping malls than high
schools now what is it 17 years later we
have twice as many shopping malls as
high suspect yeah so you can sort of see
where the trajectory is going and part
of the result of that is the the big the
bigger the store is the bigger the
shopping malls the more we find that
people buy on impulse they don't go in
maybe with a few things that they want
to get but they come home with a whole
lot more because they see literally so
much stuff and and as a result I think
it's led to a real epidemic of debt too
in the country the interesting fact is
it's many of you I think will be
probably going into college next year
and an interesting fact is that today
for the past 7 years every year in
America more Americans have declared
personal bankruptcy than have graduated
from college that started in 1996 and
has continued every year since then
speaking of historically tracking this
what you referred to as affluenza is
there a point in American history where
this notion of now it's become standard
fare for politicians to say grow the
economy
and talk about doubling or tripling or
whatever it is that the the goal is and
it this is not challenged on either side
of the political equation as everybody
it the the difference is how you plan to
do it is there a point that you've
identified in American history where
this became the driving standard for
economic policy well it kind of started
in the in the 20s there was a big push
toward creating a kind of consumer
economy in the 20s but that there was
questioning about it particularly
churches on one side and labor movement
on the other side said that people
needed free time as much as they needed
more money and more stuff and this was a
kind of a continual battle in the 20s
there was you know which way is it gonna
go then we had the Great Depression and
the focus became much more on shortening
the work work time all of those kind of
things not you know growing but not that
wasn't the obsession then World War two
intervened and after World War two since
since World War two the United States
has really been obsessed with producing
and consuming as the primary value so
that to talk about reducing working
hours really dropped out of the picture
virtually completely the idea of that we
could use our productivity to give us
more leisure to give us more time for
other values family community civic
participation all those kind of things
that got dropped from the picture after
World War two and then the 50s boomin
has never really come back into the
discussion so both parties now will tell
you it's just it's a difference about
how they're gonna do it but that they
want to grow the economy faster than the
other and they want the GDP to rise the
fastest what they don't tell you is that
the GDP is a pretty poor measurement of
the health and quality of life in a
society if the Exxon Valdez and I don't
know if any of you remember that but
that's the ship that that sank in Alaska
and spilled its oil all over the place
in Prince William Sound back in 1989
if the Exxon Valdez had gotten to port
with its oil it would have done far less
for the GDP for the gross domestic
product than it did by crashing into a
reef and spilling its oil everywhere and
having to have that cleaned up GDP
counts all the bats as well as the goods
and council
plus my distinct disadvantage here and
then interest in being truthful is
normally we like to ask those kind of
poll questions how many of you been to a
mall and I can't ask how many of the
working people in the audience wish
they'd work less hours because they're
all my coworkers okay we can't talk
about that on the air can we but on this
another the book is filled with
fascinating statistics things that
really grab your attention like the more
shopping malls the schools
speaking of Potomac most tell us the one
about national parks and the mall
they're Shenandoah National Park is that
correct in Virginia is the most visited
national park in the country yes but it
has less visitors than Potomac males
yeah yeah but of course visitors to mall
and just include everyday people as well
I mean it is a little bit of a their
remote place right right do day trips
right I mean you know malls are kind of
where where people spend a lot of their
their time today and and there's
something obviously some enjoyable
things there but you can really get
trapped into into a deaf culture and
let's take a look at another clip that
is relevant to the students are on our
audience about this movement of
marketing specifically to students
certainly see that in the music industry
other places let's look at it and this
is maybe before we roll the tape if you
could set this up for us this is the
marketing seminar in Orlando yeah this
is a Disneyworld actually and it's a
thing an annual event called Kidpower
that the advertisers who are advertising
to children teenagers and so forth all
come together and they trade strategies
and then groups they have groups
organizations called brand child whose
slogan is brand children not
grandchildren and so forth these kind of
groups come together and they figure out
how best to manipulate uuuuu and so
forth okay let's take a look and then
we'll talk a little more about it
kids love advertising it's a gift it's
something they want there's something to
be said by the way about being there
first
and about branding children and owning
them in that way it's called kids power
but it's really about
things to kids in boys advertising it is
an aggressive play pattern it is
conferences like this marketers
discussed the latest strategies for
reaching chile an anti-social behavior
in pursuit of a product is a good thing
i think all parents in america one want
to know where that man lives and social
behavior in pursuit of a product is a
good thing said with no irony no tongue
and sharing you know no and this is the
idea in fact that the idea is in the
world of marketing parents your parents
are called the gatekeepers they stand
between you between the marketers
themselves and your money and their
money and so marketers want to increase
what they call the NAG factor sort of
obvious what that means to get you to
get kids to pressure their parents to
buy more and give the kids more to buy
more and so forth and they found that
that one of the ways to do that is make
parents seem like idiots I mean you know
the old fools will fold all this kind of
stuff it's a change old days advertising
was kind of parents know best and they
aim that they would target the ads but
you know do best for your kids by
such-and-such now it's all targeted and
parents are idiots and you know you've
got to stand it stand out make your make
your stand and so forth so it's just
sort of pushing this aggressive
antisocial behavior that's used to sell
the product particularly to boys Langly
high school do you have vending machines
in the high school yeah and what about
any other overt advertising do you have
scoreboards advertising on scoreboards
things like that
what about channel one do you have
channel one in your school okay
the next clip that we have takes a look
at a dilemma for a school in Colorado
that use it at use that advertising to
fill a void I mean it's easy to be
critical of schools for going commercial
but in this is a story that makes you
rethink that let's take a look pretty
common now commercials are entering
America's schools in other ways
at North junior high school they call
this the 7up bus it's one of several in
the city of Colorado Springs which have
ads painted boldly on their sides no one
else had ever put ads on the sides of
school buses we were the first ones that
ever done it Colorado Springs is a
prosperous rapidly growing city but for
years the schools here have been victims
of affluenza people tend to sail out by
a boat instead of giving money to the
schools matter of fact the school levy
has not passed here for capital since
1972 and for operations since 1969
school superintendent Kenneth Burnley
turned to advertisers to increase
revenues at Wasson high school most of
the ads are for the snack foods but
students are warned against in their
health classes
I wish we could charge for all that
product placement we're doing today
the the you know this is not a
superintendent who is just mindlessly
selling his students eyeballs or his
community's eyeballs to advertisers this
guy has a rationale it makes sense yeah
I mean they're the schools schools often
are facing tougher budget situations all
of those kind of things you've probably
heard it in your own schools and this
kind of thing is is pretty common these
days is it a good thing I mean this
private public partnership to fill a
void where there's a need that's not
being filled through taxation or other
revenues I guess it depends how it's
done and I'm not sure I know the right
way to do it but I suspect that it's not
a great idea at least in my mind to have
ads in schools that say things like M&Ms
are better than straight A's you know is
it a matter of the product or just
advertising in general in other words
what is the problem is it any type of
advertising in a school environment or
is it the type of advertising well I
think it's a tricky one and I mean I
guess I think that schools ought to
remain ad free that that would be that
we ought to we had to have some places
in society where you're not constantly
being barraged by commercial messages
and there are very few places where
that's true you know this this may sound
like a joke but I honestly wouldn't be
surprised to see ads turning up on the
backs of pews in churches someday soon
let's go to our first question hi
morning my name is Chris Russo and I'm a
junior at Langley high school my first
question concerns with teenagers and
spending money another statistic is that
teenagers now spend about a billion
dollars do with all the marketing the
advertising and spend about a billion
dollars now with all the money that we
made the money that we earn from our
parents my question is you say that
advertisers are always marketing toward
kids always want teens to go and nag
their parents but how much of that
responsibility goes falls on to the
parents to take a look at the product
and realize no I shouldn't give them the
money to buy it and take a look at the
product and realize you know this isn't
a good idea
I mean how much of the responsibility
falls on the parent analyzing what the
marketers are targeting to the to the
children do your parents manage your
spending they do to an extent yes they
do
I mean as far as cell phones as far as
going out and spending gas money I mean
I don't I don't I don't have a credit
card I don't get you know 200 I don't
ask my parents for $200 to go out
anytime I want I'm very they're very
fiscal when it comes to me and them
giving me money I got a close-up ad
nauseum t-shirt on the way out it's half
off I can I can give it to you today one
time only that's an excellent question
and obviously parents do bear a
responsibility and as a parent myself I
I'm you know I I deal with that kind of
issue and I think parents have to do the
best job that they can but that I think
they need a little help I think when you
look at here's a parent who's all in
many cases now parents are working
longer than ever they have you know they
have less time their their situation is
very very tight in many kinds of ways
and they are facing a brush that's
coming from some of the priciest minds
in America I mean the best paid
psychologists using the focus groups the
kinds of things following the kids
around everything that they do targeting
them trying to manipulate them I think
it's a tough job for parents this is not
to let parents off the hook but there
are many there are other societies that
recognize that it's not a great idea to
target children with this kind of thing
particularly children under the age of
12 who often have no even understanding
that they're being advertised to how do
you react to that notion of the parents
need some help well I mean there's
always going to be a time in place where
children are going to see advertisements
and I mean it's sometimes and there are
a lot of movies and shows that are shown
for teenagers and the more mature
audiences and even they will they will
have commercials for you know to sell
games and things to the younger children
there always be programs and times where
the children are gonna be by themselves
and they will see you know the
advertising by themselves and they might
have some pocket money on them and
decide to go out and spend it but I
believe that you know parents as you
said nowadays they're not always in the
house around they don't always have the
hours to go and spend all the time with
the children I think it's a
forty minutes or something like that to
spend time yeah it's I mean I believe
that the parents should take some
responsibility that you know work is
very important you know work in the
materialistic world you need to make
money but the fact that to raise
children to become you know more savvy
to become more fiscally responsible in
life so we can prevent this debt that
you know this debt the American Society
has become you know accustomed to and
with all this personal in bankruptcy it
should be I think there should be more
emphasis placed on the on the on both
you know in the business world and in
the political world to kind of you know
give parents more time for their
children you know lessen the workload I
don't know how this would work I mean I
don't know I haven't read the book and
that's actually a follow-up question is
what type of strategies or advice if you
gave any in your book that would somehow
kind of offset all this marketing
barrage and all this materialism well I
could not agree with you more in fact my
current campaign and my passion the
thing that I'm working on is a movement
called take back your time and it's
really what the intention of in some
ways beginning to reduce this enormous
and growing workload that people have I
was recently in the Netherlands just a
few weeks ago and it is a common thing
in Holland today most parents who have
kids one of the parents is working four
days a week the other parent is working
three usually it's the guy working for
now both both parts so they're working
about 70 percent of time so that they
had half time for their kids now the
Dutch government recognizes that that
this is an important thing that parents
have time time for kids so their tax
policy other kinds of policies really
encourage this kind of part-time they
have full health benefits because those
are provided nationally there other
benefits are prorated their taxes are
reduced in order to actually encourage
parents to take the time instead of the
money there are many things like that
that we could begin to do and and I
honestly believe that time is the real
thing that we are sacrificing big time
for our consumption binge and and and
that's something that could help working
parents with
I agree with you you know this notion of
helping parents a couple weeks ago we we
had a discussion here on the whole FCC
cracked down on indecency that Howard
Stern and the post Superbowl fall out of
the Janet Jackson halftime show but one
of the things that came up is that
seemingly advertisers get a free ride
here that most of the criticism is of
content of entertainment programming or
of other things like that but nobody was
in outraged about the sexually explicit
Superbowl ads they were only worried
about the halftime show is this
something you find that there's some
sort of hands-off notion when it comes
to Madison Avenue bus those liberal
Hollywood producers or others always get
nailed well I think that's probably true
certainly the explicit stuff in the
advertising is is more common today than
it has been yeah I think there's a sense
that anything is okay if you want to
sell products that this is the market
and we let it go and and I have a
different feeling about that we do talk
a lot about family values and about
these kinds of things and that's a clear
entertainment programming is free market
- yes it is that's true it's true but it
is you're right it's criticized there
and unless often criticized in the
advertising it may be slightly less
explicit I so I'm trying to figure it
helped me help us figure out why is
there this inconsistency why is one
scrutinized than another not I don't
know I mean I honestly I'm not sure I'm
surprised that I I think that we should
be being looking at both these things
but beyond that in terms of Family
Values I think we have to understand
that time as a family value and the time
may be the most important and essential
family value out there that without time
without parents who are working longer
and longer or and schedules for kids and
parents and everything that are just so
tight one thing after another after
another it's really hard to to do some
of these things to think about the
marketing the techniques the things that
are being used and so you know hallmark
will or somebody will say well if you
can't be there for your kid at least put
a card on
their pillow that says I'm sorry I can't
be here I gotta work I mean this is what
we've come to have a nice day fix your
have a nice day yeah hi hi my name's
Josh Carver I'm a senior at Langley high
school you were talking earlier about
the documentary Super Size Me which I
recently just saw only a few weeks ago
and I thought firstly I thought it was
brilliant I thought it was great but one
of the shortcomings one of the things I
didn't particularly like about it was
that it's bent I'd say 95% of the movie
talking about the problem and the issues
but not proposing any solutions you've
offered a whole lot of interesting and
insightful information on whole
affluenza epidemic but I was wondering
as to whether or not you could maybe
provide some information like some ways
to maybe solve the problem or some
follow-up fairness to our guests they
didn't follow up yeah well I'll tell you
I've only been censored on PBS once in
all the years that I've produced for
them and so I'll tell you this story
maybe c-span will censor - I hope not
never happen in any case so we produced
a little segment it was kind of a little
PSA that was it for the program escape
from affluenza that was kind of a little
humorous tip for one thing you can do to
avoid the debt and we call it a credit
card prophylactic or a credit card
condom in other words you take a little
a little envelope the size of a credit
card that you put your credit card in
and on the outside of that it says do I
really need this could I borrow it from
someone else how many hours will I have
to work to pay for it will I use it are
the resources renewable a few questions
like that so every time you pull out
your credit card to buy something and
you kind of consider this and it we
think it protects people from reckless
spending and allows us to practice safe
shopping so you know things like that
about PBS said well we can't use the
word prophylactic you know PBS was
probably just pledge week or something
that was not only they said that they
they said that 50 to 75 of their small
markets simply they have to put any word
that might upset people and that was one
then would not show the program and that
they would not put a program on
prime-time that wasn't shown by 50 or 75
of their smaller markets but that's
that's the the humorous side
I mean clearly in the book we have a
whole list of things that people can do
and we kind of treat them like in the
disease model and we call them aspirin
and chicken soup bed rest
things like that but they're really
something something different
so really about you know checking and
really tabulating you're spending seeing
what you're doing what you pay I mean
taking a month and actually doing that
really calculating how much did I spend
what did I do with the product and stuff
that it's an amazing exercise and people
find that they are just frittering away
all kinds of stuff secondly coming
together with other people and sharing
these experiences we have what we call
voluntary simplicity study circles where
people come together and talk about how
they can cut back for we I call one that
I call it vaccinations and and vitamins
and it's the whole idea of media
literacy in schools how many of you in
your high school have had a course in
media literacy anybody hmm it's getting
a little more common now but it's
interesting to see that that there's
still lots of places obviously that
don't have it what media literacy
courses in high schools do is they teach
students to really understand how these
ads work how they target them how the
how they manipulate and so forth and you
you really make you make ads you do
those kind of things and you understand
the process and therefore it kind of
vaccinates you a little bit against the
manipulation that goes on so there are
lots of things that we offer I also
think that certain public policy things
may be important of ideas like
progressive consumption taxes which have
been been proposed that really hit you
know the more reckless you're spending
that the harder that hits or certainly
issues like giving people more more time
shortening work hours and things like
but there's a lot of a lot of things
that I don't have time to go into them
all now your question question is well
taken and too often all too often I
think when I first got into documentary
I saw so many good documentaries that I
thought wow these this really does lay
out the problem
it really does convince me that we have
got a problem but it leaves me feeling
like oh my god now what do I do
there's just no answer so you feel like
being an ostrich and sticking your head
in the sand and I didn't want to do that
I did want to offer things solutions so
I think we do do that although there's
still a tendency do you do you look at
your solutions as an economist might in
other words are they practical could you
apply the solutions and not have a crash
of our whole system sure and our
solutions go at range from everything
from the purely personal and very little
choices that people can make that that
can help them stay out of debt and can
get to on up to the big policy questions
is there anything that government can do
that makes this easier now if we were to
suddenly really reduce our consumption
that is if we were to wipe out affluenza
tomorrow in the United States that
wouldn't be a good thing either I mean
we would have a big economic crash
there's no question about it if we just
stopped spending and so forth and that
would would would go throughout the
society but it's not gonna happen that
way if we're successful at all in
getting people to think about these
things and begin to change our
lifestyles and our behavior it'll be a
gradual process that will take a
generation and this economy it is big
enough and flexible enough that it can
respond to those kind of changes it
better I mean I think you know the
things that we're seeing out there like
global warming like the destruction of
ecosystems all of these kind of things
show us that we cannot just keep doing
the same things growing the same way
cooking in common because Kingdom's
gonna come awful soon and it's not going
to be pleasant so we've got it we've got
to change we've got to do it Josh I got
a hot tip in my earpiece that you'll
follow up question real quick follow-up
question um in your opinion do you think
you'll be better to try and reform
society on a mass scale or more
grassroots
type things like what you're saying with
the little credit card thing or do you
think would be better to actually try
and do a whole sort of Legends push
legislation through and on a more mass
scale I'm just curious which we need
well I honestly think we need to do both
III think that change has to happen at
all levels there's a there's a just
there are a lot of things that people
can do just being much more conscious is
helpful and you can improve your own
life in a personal sense but we've got
we've got big social and environmental
crises that we're facing that I think
also need us to act collectively and to
use government I think we we've gotten
into a tough situation in this country
where there's been so much
anti-government feeling that you know we
really have this sentiment that anything
government it does or will ever do is a
bad thing I think that's fundamentally
destructive and I think it's a very
different attitude than people have in
other industrial countries so you go to
Europe and you really I think you're
really seeing tremendous kinds of
programs that are enhancing for the
environment enhancing for people's time
for their families for all these kind of
things that are in part instituted and
promoted by government policy longer
vacations all of those kind of things we
could learn a lot from other countries
but but you know we tend not to do that
so I think what he's saying to Josh is
if you want a solution move right get
active get active hi my name is Peter
Matz I'm also from Langley high school
and I'm I'm wondering do you feel do you
think that the government is as
susceptible to affluenza and
overspending as people in general and if
so the Conservatives I was surprised
that you said that you were hearing
responses from conservatives as well
do you think that the Conservatives who
are responding to this concept will
develop more liberal tendencies in terms
of like the government government
regulation of the economy and that
direction well you know I don't know
that yeah I mean you're still here I
still
hear from people that they they buy a
lot of our arguments but they want to do
the individual things and they would
like they really distrust government so
much they want to keep government out of
it for me right now that's fine I mean
do the individual things work on this in
any way that you you feel that you can
if you don't if you don't believe
government can do anything but I
honestly think that there are things
that we can do important things that we
can do with public policy and I hope you
know the government has affluenza I know
there's no question in the sense that
our debt is too skyrocketing out of
control right now but of course a lot of
that has to do with military spending
and things and at the same time
coupling that with a massive tax
giveaway to two rich Americans so that
the money isn't there so the debt of the
government debt that we're facing is
both is certainly in part this whole
idea that we will just cut taxes and
encourage people to go out and do
private spending let's take a look at
another clip from the program that
relates to what you two gentlemen were
just talking about this is about the
income gap and it this might be an
example of one of the areas government
my actor might not act affluenza affects
people across all income barriers people
who have a lot but want more than feel
themselves almost empty inside once they
get more and people who want for life's
basics but still find themselves almost
taunted by glittering embellishments and
in recent years the gap between the two
groups has been growing in fact the gap
between rich and poor Americans is now
the widest in any industrial nation
low-income people see it as an issue of
inequity how is it that I see all these
people around me getting wealthier and
wealthier doing better and better
gaining more and more material goods at
a time when I'm falling farther and
farther behind if you look carefully at
the big consumer boom since the 1980s I
think one of the things you'll find is
that it's fairly heavily
and traded in the upper part of the
middle class and above now you know when
we talk about this in terms of
conservative or liberal or Republican or
democratic we just came out of prior to
the Bush administration eight years of a
Democrat in the White House and still
this gap has been growing if you get
frightened again the gap has essentially
been widening since the mid 70s and
that's in contrast to a situation in
many other industrial countries where
where where things are getting
relatively more equal in the United
States the our economy was really
growing more equal and kill about the
early 70s and I think that this whole
increasing division of wealth and in the
United States this gap really does in
many ways both encourage affluenza and
it encourages the epidemic of overwork
in our society it encourages it at every
level the people who are doing well who
were wealthy who are getting the big tax
breaks all these kind of things I think
balal work more I'll do this because I
can buy all the extra things I can
retire early I can invest in the stock
market so they're they're pushing harder
working and then buying the people in
the middle feel like well this the bar
is way up the status bar of what you
have to have to lead the good life to
keep up with the Joneses is always going
up and I can get that but only by
working longer and often by going into
debt so they get trapped in this cycle
and the people at the at the bottom in
our society the poor in America really
have lost income real income they've
lost buying power since the 1970s in in
real terms they have to work longer to
do more of these kind of things often
get more in debt just to make ends meet
so I think we've got to start trying to
find a way to make our society somewhat
more equal all right go ahead please hi
my name is Ben Schreiber I'm also a
senior from Langley high school it seems
to me like on paper when consumers are
spending a lot they're getting a lot of
their spending back to them through
stocks the economy is high what do you
think would be some long-term and
term effects of reduced consumer
spending on the economy as a whole
well I think ultimately the the the
economy if we were more conscious
consumers and spenders would be more
stable over the long term I think we
would avoid these sort of boom and bust
kind of cycles that that come from that
I don't think we're gonna see an any
early repeat of this big stock market
explosion that occurred in the 90s
because it had a lot to do with this
whole calm phenomenon which is drop down
and isn't that necessarily likely to -
to realign we really have to ask the
basic question what is an economy for we
have to say not just you know do we want
the biggest gross domestic product you
know that we want to have a gross or
domestic product and every other country
but what is our economy for if it's just
for producing and consuming more stuff
that what we want or is our economy for
other kinds of things like having
healthy people having good families and
strong communities a strong Civic and
political life a good clean environment
to pass on to our children then if our
if our economy is for those things then
I think we need to begin to move in a
different direction and get away from
this constant emphasis on and and it may
mean a little bit lower GDP but I think
that's a choice we should make that's
that's a trade-off that other countries
are talking about and a trade-off that
we should be willing to make as well
yeah I actually have a follow-up to that
I like what do you think would be the
effect on the job market I know a lot of
these corporations that are marketing to
Americans are providing a lot of jobs
how do you think the reduced consumer
spending would affect that well I think
if we keep things exactly
as they are and we still continue this
notion that Americans should full-time
jobs should increase an increase I mean
right now full-time working Americans
are working longer hours than they were
when I was your age I mean when I was in
my first year in college I was told that
by the year 2000 we'd have a big problem
in the United States too much leisure
time automation with all those things
would lead us we'd be working 15 or 20
hour work week we'd have 7 to 10 weeks
of vacation with all the these gains and
in fact today we're working more now
what happened we got the increases in
productivity we could have made the
choice to take some of that in time and
one of the ways that we can solve this
job crisis this unemployment crisis is
not always assuming that we need to add
more jobs at 40 hours a week 50 weeks a
year no vacation all those kind of
things but we ought to share the
existing work and reduce the hours and
spread it out that's that's that's what
we talked about back in 1933 the United
States Senate actually passed a bill
that would have made the official work
week in the United States 30 hours 70
years ago they said 30 hours and they
were then a spreader anything more than
that would be overtime seven years ago
we can't get it down to 40 if we would
share the work and all of us work 35
hours a week and have more vacation time
and time for our families and stuff
there'd be plenty of jobs to go around
that's an alternate reality that I'm
built for our attire to be your test
case well let's take a look at another
clip so far we focused on the United
States and the impact of affluenza in
the United States let's take a look at a
clip that talks about global impact
one-fifth of the world's people live in
abject poverty dying slowly of hunger
and disease billions of others also
desperately need more material goods
yet where they do consume as much as we
do the result could be an environmental
crisis there is absolutely no way that
everyone in the world can can live at
that standard of affluence because the
Earth's ecosystems simply will not stand
it mister Majan if every Chinese
household had two cars as this car show
in Beijing reveals they're already on
that road
Western products and advertising are
pouring into developing countries it is
creating a groundwork for an incredible
global disaster combined with a
population explosion not expected to
peak for decades that consumption boom
threatens to devour the world's reserves
of oil and other resources within the
lifetime of our grandchildren we've set
the example the American consumer each
year you consume fantastic amounts of
food clothing housing amusements
appliances and services of all kinds
since 1950 Americans alone have used
more resources than everyone who ever
lived before the best those are an
imponderable types of Statistics since
1950 we've use more resources than
everyone who's ever lived who ever lived
before us yeah since 1950 we've had more
people on the earth overall than we ever
had you know all in all the years before
put together the gentleman who you
interview in that clip interesting story
his job originally was to help travel
other countries and help them set up us
type you can do like systems and now
he's got a different tune yeah
absolutely right his name is David
korten and he was a a professor at the
Harvard Business School Stanford
Business School he worked for the agency
for international development and other
groups to go out and actually promote
high consumption sort of American
lifestyles in developing countries and
he came to the conclusion that he was
really kind of creating disasters
destroying environmental systems
destroying cultures and ways of lives in
those those countries and and again this
is the issue we our scientists have
estimated that for everyone on earth to
suddenly adopt the American lives
and it's hard to tell people that they
shouldn't do what they see us doing if
we're not gonna model some of the kind
of behavior for everyone on earth that
adopt our lifestyle would require four
or five planets to make that possible
another in other words were three or
four planets short so we're you know
we've got a somehow deal with these
questions they're not going to be easy
but they're certainly going to face you
as the the next generation coming into
positions of power and leadership and
policy and I hope you'll think about
them hi my name is Dmytro Lowe and I am
a senior at Langley high school and you
spoke earlier about people who are over
shopping and overspending and people
falling into personal bankruptcy and I'm
sure you agree when I say that I'm a lot
of that can be attributed to the
widespread use of credit cards and
charging purchases as opposed to using
cash that people have on hand and my
question to you is what advice can you
give to students my age and people my
generation about approaching credit
cards and signing up for credit cards
and people who want to establish our
credit at a young age we are worried
about falling to dead or personal
bankruptcy Wow I mean that is a good
question and it's just really it's it's
a matter of being conscious about these
things and again you know one credit
card I mean you get correct a credit
card is a good is useful for many many
things but the idea that you have more
of all kinds of credit cards all of
which have these great credit lines and
things and you can spend here and spend
here that comes back and bites you I
mean you if you're careful and if you do
what 60% of Americans don't do which is
to pay off your credit card balance each
month credit can be a perfectly good
thing but you have to understand that
because it is a problem I talked
recently with a college professor
who told me that credit card debt was
the leading cause of college dropouts
today there was a situation a couple of
years ago were a couple of sorority
sisters at the University of Oklahoma
actually committed suicide by hanging
themselves because they were so deep in
credit card debt and yet they felt that
they couldn't even talk to their parents
about it they didn't know what
to do and that was coming home so you
just have to be careful because they're
gonna be out there pushing this and you
know that the mailbox is just filled
with these kinds of offers you no no no
payments here no this and but it sounds
like if you're thinking about it you're
already a step ahead of the the crowd
and you put you're probably on your way
to doing the right thing the good news
is that we are hearing from people in
groups like consumer credit counseling
and things like that that young the
generation now coming just starting to
come into college is actually a little
more careful about it than than the one
that's just leaving college I hope that
that's true one of the things you
address in the documentary is the whole
political environment for any type of a
movement that would be led by
politicians from the top down and we
have a clip here to show you that it
talks about this historically takes a
look at Jimmy Carter let's take a look
at that clip now and we'll talk about
this in the 1960s is small but vocal
counterculture called for a simpler way
of life then the 1974 a nationwide oil
shortage caused many people to wonder if
we might run out of resources by 1979
even our president was questioning the
American Dream too many of us now tend
to worship self-indulgence and
consumption part of Jimmy Carter's
failure was his lack of recognition of
how deeply seeded the high wide and
handsome notion of economic growth and
capital development had become in the
modern American psyche since mr. Carter
lost by a landslide no presidential
candidate is dared challenge the goal of
infinite economic growth
Bill Clinton and Al Gore appreciated the
sentiments contained in this old shaker
him but they pledged to grow the economy
faster than their opponents could Bob
Dole and Jack Kemp's opinion we should
aim at doubling the size of the American
economy in the next 15 years when Jack
Camp offered that opinion his debate
opponent Vice President Gore never
questioned whether it would really be a
good idea for Americans to consume twice
as much as they do now now earlier when
a student asked whether this needs to be
grassroots or top-down you said both we
need both do you see any opportunity for
a national politician to lead such a
movement to say in front of the American
people what you need is a lower standard
of living well you know and I don't
think it's a lower standard you know I
think we need a different quality of
life and it may be somewhat less
materialistic but I think it would be a
higher standard of living in terms of
our health or all kinds of things our
families the stuff that psychologists in
fact say is is most important in terms
of what makes us happy I think we'd have
a higher standard of living a current
example might be gas prices yeah you
don't see people saying you know maybe
we should drive less you see these
movements to force lower gas prices yeah
yeah and and we go to Europe and talk
about that and people think Americans
are kind of crazy I mean they would be
we might be better off as a society if
if we if you know back when Gary Hart
when he ran for president then first
proposed the 50 cent tax on gas had we
done it then we might have really it
might have really paid off for us now we
might have mass transit all kinds of
other kinds of things that would make
make transportation easier in this
country and and better for us and we
might be less dependent on automobiles
but we didn't we we don't have the
leadership we might have thought that it
would have come from Al Gore because Al
Gore back in in 1992 wrote a what I
consider a terrific book it was called
earth in the balance
and Al Gore in that book said many of
the things that that I've been saying
that you know we just simply can't grow
forever that the environment won't stand
it that and that besides it's not even
good for us it's it's it's resulted in
the fact that Americans are the least
healthy of all industrial nations that
we've got all kinds of other other
problems and we need to look at
something different Al Gore said all
those things then after he became
vice-president it's as if he forgot I
mean it was like the body's the mine
snatcher came and took Al Gore and there
was a different Al Gore and this seems
to happen to American politicians that
even the ones who really do understand
these issues and I think some of them do
actually think John Kerry does but
they're worried about about bringing
this up because there's so much money
involved in politics and we what do you
think the ultimate consequences are for
democracy and this in this regard that
Benjamin barber who may have a close up
staff know a noted scholar on democracy
talks about a global transformation of
citizens into consumers and he talks
about this gloomily as far as the
prospects for democracy do you make this
connection that affluence is a threat to
civic engagement and democracy and well
I think it's certainly a threat to our
democracy to our political participation
as we spend more of our lives intent on
personal consumption all this kind of
stuff and we work longer at the same
time and both parents are working all
these kinds of things there's simply
less time left over for civic and
political involvement so in the after
the 2000 election about a third of the
non voters said well I just didn't have
time to vote now I don't really buy that
excuse it doesn't take all that long to
vote but what takes time is to
understand the issues this California
for example in the last election I have
Californians how to choose between a
hundred and thirty five candidates for
governor we've got all kinds of big
ballot issues and things coming up this
may be the most important election
coming up
in the history of this country but how
do people understand the issues if
they're so caught up in work and spend
and consume that that they can't
participate that they can't get involved
time for a very quick final question I
don't know how quick this can be so I'll
try to make it as brief we talked about
the Super Bowl thing and how Janet
Jackson everyone's big backlash but yet
like the next week when Oprah Winfrey
had a show about sexually explicit teen
language on network TV that seemed to
have been all right but not for Howard
Stern to talk so there was some sort of
a standard was set of what is more
appropriate than not my question are you
concerning that is what constitutes
appropriate spending and where do you
draw the line on this affluenza for
example I might buy a TV and I don't
need a TV to survive to live in this
world but you know TV for entertainment
pay where do you draw the line and I'm
sorry to catch you if we need to get you
an answer and we have about 20 seconds
to do that well I'm gonna leave that to
people to draw the line individually I
can't draw the line for everybody and
I'm certainly not suggesting that we
live in a cave and and you know put on a
hair shirt and give up all these kinds
of mana we don't need to do that that
isn't the point I I think we could have
a quite affluent society if we did a few
things if we were more careful about
making and consuming products that
lasted longer that were that we're
durable if we were very careful about
recycling and reusing things if we use
tax policy to penalize waste and
encourage savings and things things like
that we could still have a very good
material standard of living and it even
better than today overall quality of
life and but as far as the choice for
you and you and you you have to make
that choice individually you have to
think you know what's really important
to me what makes what brings me
happiness and I think you think about it
you think you really will understand
that it's family connections
relationships friends all of these kind
of things time spent in the natural
world these are the things that really
ultimately make us happy so try to be
the final word as many good discussions
do it ends with a question what is it
what is a good life to you this is the
producer and author John de Graaff
affluenza is the book and the
documentary that was seen on PBS want to
thank you for joining us today thank you
very much appreciate having the time
thanks to all of you and congratulations
on graduation I hope you enjoy your
summer before you're off to your
institutions of higher learning we will
be back next week our summer break does
not start yet and we will have a couple
interesting topics to discuss we'll join
you we'll see you then in the meantime
for all of us at the Newseum freedom
forum and close the foundation I'm John
molesky thanks for watching
Saturday night on c-span advice from
today